hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde wissen dass ich mich einfach
frage hast du schon lukas neues video
gesehen von wem
luca laser luca von crafter ach der lauf
ich bin dann jetzt schon einfach alter
du ahnst es nicht silvia hat heute beim
privatdetektiv angerufen und gefragt ob
sie morgen beschattet werden kann weil
es der 36 grad werden sollen
hahahaha
eure wortwitze ich komm nicht klar weißt
du warum mäuse keinen alkohol trinken
warum weil sie angst vorm katar haben
bitte geh dich vergraben schaufel geht
auf mich
apa stimmt es dass du isas freut jetzt
bei uns einzieht ist es nicht etwas
überstürzt sie kennen sich doch erst
seit ein paar monaten hat du erstmal ein
freund sein sie was denn hier einzieht
ist eine handcreme da
wurden die shots definitiv gefeiert
alles ist gut solange du wild bist naja
also bei einem wildunfall ist es
beispielsweise nicht so gut wenn man das
wild ist oh mein gott
ich
frag mich bei euch wirklich gar nichts
mehr ich liebe meine autokorrektur man
spart zeitung macht keine fohlen mehr
und alles ist einfach suppe vielleicht
solltest du mal über ein neues handy
nachdenken ja
hätte diese leute die sich einfach schon
so sehr auf ihre autokorrektur verlassen
dass sie einfache gar nicht mehr richtig
schreiben können
also ich denke einfach bruder wenn ihr
früher mit einer schreibmaschine
schreiben müssen als er ihr wert ein
wort weit gekommen eine vier in
deutschland wir sind sehr wütend marios
warum hast du mit der hausarbeit ich
einfach früher angefangen mir war keine
männliche zeigen was ich hatte keinen
bock hausarrest vier wochen
das
head auch von mir und meiner
damals geschickt werden können da wollte
sich meine mom einen kaffee machen und
hat die tasse rausgezogen dabei er hat
sie eine andere tasse mit runtergezogen
die sun kaputt gegangen und dann meinte
ich ha ha vollidiot ist ja nicht mehr
alle tassen im schrank
ja eine woche habe ich dann den
fußballplatz leider nicht mehr gesehen
jetzt ist es soweit kathi ich muss
abnehmen
was ist passiert ich war beim dönermann
und habe zwei dollar bestellt oder er
hat einfach nur geantwortet willst du
die zwei mitglieder oder direkt hier
essen aha du fettsack das als auch rhi
label um mein gott irgendwie könnte
jeder whatsapp wirklich heute auch auf
mich angewendet werden kommen wir nun
allerdings zu einem richtigen mama
oddset fällen mal wieder und zwar es ist
einfach so typische eltern humor
brauchen sie eine brille und da wird
halt dann das kreuz gesetzt und die
person schreibt auch einfach lustig mama
ja
wir schicken
jetzt auch eigentlich die ganze zeit so
komische weihnachts videos rum
gut dann sind
so peinlich ist wahltag
wer von euch freut sich darüber wenn man
einen minion weihnachts video bekommt
wie diese teile der weihnachtsmützen auf
haben und merry christmas singen mehr
als zwei wochen vor heiligabend
und wer stellt diese videos überhaupt wo
ich mal wo kommen die her brasilien
hast du schon geht die hausaufgaben
gemacht um noch mal keine zeit heute
muss noch zimmer aufräumen einkaufen
papa helfen blablabla ok viel erfolg und
dann viereinhalb stunden später und
jetzt kommen nicht weiter habe bisher
nichts von den sachen gemacht die ich
heute schaffen wollte dafür habe ich
dann gewisse herausgefunden welche
brotsorten ich bin auch wieder ich dann
tatsächlich ich kapiere die hausaufgaben
nicht hör auf mit diesem wort spielen
wein doch legal sei doch nicht gleich so
eingeschnappt okay ich rufe das sek zu
dirk
kennst du die brücke die über die alster
geht ja kennedy brücke heißt gibt warum
kennst du nicht doch ich kenne die
brücke
wenn ich für jedes klatschen nach
schlechten wortwitz nur einen
einen euro bekommen hätte
ja dann würde ich jetzt hier nicht mehr
videos machen habe heute mein facebook
gelöscht warum ich habe heute direkt
beim öffnen der app wird bei der menge
und deshalb nie in deutschland gedreht
werde hier kein netz hat gesehen
ok verständlich
das sind so richtige facebook 2012
bilder - wurde aber ich weiß ich wieder
rüber leute lachen können als gott mich
schuf finger an zu grinsen und dachte
keine ahnung ob es gut geht aber lustig
wird's bestimmt
breaking news facebook will seine
mitglieder aus 2012 zurück mein reden
birgit mit einem labrador als titelbild
und immer so so minion videos auch dann
meine worte birgit meine worte einem
2012 alter facebook auch voll mit diesen
ganzen maya kalender sagt also dieses
jahr der untergang heißt
ja habe ich geglaubt immer mehr leute
sterben an zu viel zucker also könnte
man es auch kollateralschaden nennen
punkt punkt hat deine fresse junge ja
ja
ich habe gestern 24
beobachtet es gab stieg
fragezeichen
steg gleich steak
ich werde morgen zwei wie beim essen
beobachten die dich essen-werden afrika
irgendwie
irgendwie haben wir heute nur wortwitze
warum seid ihr eigentlich noch dran das
ist überhaupt nicht lustig hier weißt du
was man mal aufgefallen ist was ich muss
langsam mal nett werden
ich bin ja nicht ewig hübsch
das könnte
60 auch so von sandra gekommen sein weil
ich dachte ich wäre dumm aber guck mal
was an unserer uni tür steht und dann
ein foto von irgendwem duden paetec gmbh
schild und da steht einfache duden
institute für lerntherapie anstatt
therapie es schon peinlich wenn du der
du bist und du schreibst sachen falsch
durch meine einzige aufgabe ist es
sachen richtig zu schreiben
einzige aufgabe es ist eigentlich
lustige youtube videos zu machen und
daran scheint er schon jeden tag joel hh
tagsüber sagt man der arbeit und das
korn aber abends sagt man dann das weite
und der korn h
die anderen schickt ihm einfach einen
link von einer klinik für suchtmedizin
aus berlin
und damit würde ich das heute
ein letzten wie nennt man eine erektion
der garantiert schon kein bock mehr
bitte einfach dein maul jürgen sie
hatten was ist hier irgendwie überhaupt
für name krisenstab
ich
das ist für mich ja auch schwierig so
also man sollte jetzt auch nicht denken
dass mir das leicht fällt
zu machen
das ist ja einfach schmutz
[Musik]